so last week I played for you a clip of
one of Donald Trump's new defense
attorneys Joe takapina on MSNBC being
interviewed properly by Ari melber and
lunging at papers that Ari melber was
holding that's how Joe takapina reacted
to an actual real interview with
questions that are not just softballs we
now have a different sort of interview
what's interesting is that this was a
completely friendly interview Joe
takapina appeared last night with Fox
news's propaganda's Mark Levin
very comfortable interview very friendly
there was no lunging for papers but Joe
takapina is just as unhinged take a look
at this this is if this is the guy
that's going to defend Trump if Trump is
arrested I don't know guys I'm not sure
let's start out with just the basic
question one that really only has one
answer no matter what side of the
political fence you you sit on
does anyone actually believe that if
someone else were accused of
paying hush money to avoid a publicly
embarrassing sex scandal which the
president really denies vehemently right
which by the way never happened right
Joe
um but regardless of that if anyone else
in that situation with these set of
facts would they be prosecuted the
answer Mark by all accounts is 100 no
now what Joe takapina and this is this
is the problem when you don't have a
real interviewer a real show right like
this when you just have a softball thing
is there's two issues here number one
it's not that they're just going after
Trump for political reasons because
Michael Cohen served prison time for
participating in this very same criminal
conspiracy so if you want to be fair
Michael Cohen's crimes were committed in
service to Trump you would think that
points to maybe Trump does have some
liability here and of course secondly
the element of this that Joe takapina
doesn't include is that what is at issue
is the laundering of the hush money
through Trump's campaign and so the idea
that oh it's just political nobody else
would be arrested for hush money related
to an affair which they don't even do
well we're talking about a different
situation a different set of facts and
money laundering through a campaign next
clip and again Mark Levin is just
useless here it's what really is
troubling because if you think about it
all decent people well the politically
opposed to Donald Trump or in favor of
Donald Trump should be concerned about
this weaponization of a prosecutor's
office to go get a political opponent
because well if you can prove that
that's what happened that would be one
thing but we know Michael Cohen went to
prison over this so it's not merely a
prosecutor saying let's see if we can
get Trump on this Cohen was prosecuted
and went to prison for his involvement
in this very same incident now that
being said
I will admit I don't think the Stormy
Daniels case is the strongest case
against Trump but maybe this will open
the floodgates for other prosecutors to
say all right it's it's time it's time
here's another clip of takapina let's
hold it from the dead the Stormy Daniels
case there's no crime here the only
potential crime here Mark is that Donald
Trump was an extortion victim someone
says give me money or I'm gonna tell a
nasty story about you true or not that's
even that's absolutely irrelevant to
that equation true or not I'm going to
tell a story to the Press I'm going to
embarrass you your family unless you
give me money that's extortion 101. now
remember whether or not Trump had an
affair with Stormy Daniels whether or
not stormy extorted him which by the way
if it was extortion Trump should go
after her for extortion uh regardless
that doesn't mean Trump had to launder
the payment through his campaign which
is what's at issue here you could say
she extorted money out of me and I gave
her the money for an affair that never
happened okay then there wouldn't be a
crime except look at how it was handled
financially and again Levin won't Force
takapina to contend with that and
takapina certainly isn't going to
um this guy if this is the sort of
defense that you have to remember with
people like Trump
typically you've got your TV lawyers who
say one thing and then your court
lawyers who have to manage the the
situation in a different way sometimes
there's a little overlap like with that
Alina Haba who got herself into all
sorts of trouble being both Trump's TV
lawyer and real lawyer My Hope for Trump
is that takapina is not actually going
to be managing this for him if indeed
Trump is arrested tomorrow
one of our sponsors is curiositystream
the best place to find and watch
documentaries on politics history
science technology nature you name it
they have it curiosity stream has a
deeper collection of documentaries than
any other streaming service they add new
titles every week including exclusive
award-winning films and shows you can't
watch anywhere else I just watched
ancient engineering
fascinating insights into how stuff was
built before modern technology and the
Industrial Revolution you can watch
curiosity stream on all of your devices
phone desktop game console Smart TV I'm
always finding great documentaries on
curiosity stream that I can't find on
any other platforms it's really the only
place to go for documentaries and they
have a special deal for my audience you
can get curiosity stream for 25 off just
go to curiositystream.com Pacman and use
the code Pacman the link is down below